light is very powerful for me yet it's
also something that I'm desperate to
hold on to
it's going you know the lights are going
out
so I'm struggling to hold on to the
light
I was in art school in 79 and the eye
doctor said Mr you have an eye disease
you will be blind in 20 years
and I said what
you're telling me this bad news I'm
going to make the best art I can ever
make God damn it you know I'm going to
do it
I see very bright lights
and I can't see dim light at all I've
never seen a star in my whole life for
example I was looking at that view
towards Manhattan what I see is a very
small area maybe about half the size of
my thumb and all around that it's not
black it's not white it's not gray it
just doesn't exist
that's how I see everything else it's
just non-existence
there are a number of visually impaired
visual artists now and we do have a
facet in the art world
[Music]
light painting is a process where you
use your mind as much as your eyes it's
a very long time exposure made in a
darkened room with a flashlight
the person will be there and I will turn
off the lights and wherever I don't
paint with the flashlight it'll be black
in the picture
the fear I have about blindness is very
strong
it's a feeling that my life will not be
worthwhile if I can't say
but as a totally blind person I will
still be able to do the light painting
so it is a comfort to know that my work
is strong even though maybe in the
future I won't be able to see it
foreign